[Musique]
en juillet 2019 le chalutier usine ivan
golubev c'est la proie des flammes au
large de la mauritanie la scène
cauchemardesque vire à la tragédie
un marin ukrainien et père de famille de
39 ans oleg nicolescu manquent à l'appel
monsieur nicolescu a couru vers la salle
des machines pour voir ce qui se passait
c'est la dernière fois qu'on l'a vu
pendant qu'il est remorqué par un autre
chalutier le ivan golub est sombre sous
les flots
en ukraine la famille du marin disparu
temps d'obtenir compensation avec l'aide
d'un avocat d'odessa mais ils
n'obtiennent aucune réponse du
gestionnaire du navire une obscure
société canadienne nommé yves your
business in canada il n'y a rien au
canada cette fausse société n'a pas
d'argent et il est donc quasi impossible
d'obtenir une compensation
notre enquête dévoile des activités de
pêche illégale des allégations de fraude
et des pistes étonnant qui mène du
nouveau brunswick jusqu'à la russie et
tout ça sous le couvert de sociétés
canadiennes
la canada a car un vernis de sainteté le
vernis craque un peu on devient
tranquillement paradis pour les gens mal
intentionnés
[Musique]
nous lançons nos recherches en alberta
pour trouver la mystérieuse société y
virent business elle est située sur la
32e avenue à calgary
mais l'adresse nous mène vers un centre
commercial où se côtoient salon de
massage sex-shops et dispensaires de
cannabis
personne ici l'entreprise qui s'y
trouvent offre des services
d'incorporation et de boîtes postales le
canada permet dans certaines
juridictions
d'abord une enveloppe impénétrable
plusieurs juridictions canadiennes ne
demande même pas qui sont les
actionnaires d'une société
mais une nouvelle fuite d'informations
bancaires ultra secrète nous permet
d'aller plus loin
yves bethegnies apparaît dans les frites
en files des déclarations d'opérations
douteuses signalés par des institutions
bancaires au département du trésor
américain
ces rapports confidentiels ont été
obtenus par le site de nouvelle beauce
fine et partagé avec le consortium
international des journalistes d'
enquête et radio canada
on y découvre que la coquille de calgary
brasse de grosses affaires elle a reçu
des millions de dollars provenant de
comptes bancaires suisses
les données révèlent aussi qu'une autre
mystérieuse société canadienne aussi
annick sécurisé nber a reçu des
virements bancaires similaire provenant
des mêmes sources
souvent le même jour leur empreinte
bancaire est presque identique selon son
site web océanique fisheries fait aussi
à faire dans le domaine des pêches
elle est incorporée au nouveau brunswick
c'est dans cette province que nous
poursuivons nos recherches dans la ville
de saint jean avec l'aide d'une collègue
de sib ici
et se rend à venir on sait où logent
océanique fisheries selon la fuite
l'avenue world c est une pépinière de
sociétés écran 14 sociétés écrans au 505
roissy et 18 autres à quelques coins de
rue de là puis au 336 3 tic un magasin
au ps qui loue des boîtes postales
personne ne peut nous aider aussi à
nekrif chemise à changer d'adressé et se
trouve maintenant ici sur la rue
charlotte
[Musique]
au canada il plus simple d'enregistrer
une compagnie que d'obtenir une carte de
bibliothèque
on n'a pas à se présenter en personne on
n'a pas donné une photo
on n'a pas à s'identifier qu'une carte
d'identité pour une compagnie c'est un
problème des sites web étrangers offrent
même des services d'incorporation de
société néo-brunswickoise en vantant les
mérites de la province
aucune exigence qu'il y ait des
administrateurs au canada aucune
information à fournir au sujet des
véritables propriétaires et les
avantages d'exportation nos
problématiques vers la russie
suggérant à mots couverts une façon de
contourner des sanctions internationales
on voit de plus en plus des services
étrangers maintenant vendre ailleurs
dans le monde en europe de l'est en
russie
la capacité d'en racheter des compagnies
canadiennes en vendant les avantages de
pas citer du canada donc c'est ce qu' il
ya des gens qui font de la règlement
volontaires qui ont un modèle d'affaires
basé sur je ne pose pas de questions
dont je n'ai pas de réponse c'est
inacceptable c'est dangereux c'est très
dangereux de keven arsenault et député
du parti vert du nouveau brunswick
il veut que sa province resserre les
règles d'incorporation des sociétés et
augmente la transparence ça me frustre
tainio green du coût de sa voix que par
notre capacité de l'axis de d'agir à
rendre notre régis dé des entreprises
plus transparent qu'on est complice à
des stratagèmes international co éco
disait faites vous veut pas sur ma vie
de l'avis de tout le monde même si c'est
d'aider des compagnies écran de
l'étranger qui viennent ici ont rien
d'autre qu'une façade
c'est un effet sur une crédibilité en
tant que néo brunswickois
la fuite contient un autre indice
important elle révèle que océanique fait
chemise lim société a pris ben jawad
cette société située de l'autre côté de
l'atlantique en lettonie
dans le passé on traite a été sanctionné
pour des pêches illégales ou sénégal
selon un rapport de greenpeace des
chalutiers lié à wall street est aussi
un excellent service similaire à celui
ci au pêché illégalement dans des zones
réservées aux bateaux mauritaniens selon
l'étude de l'experte vancouvéroise diab
et la bible c'est massif cdd des
centaines et des centaines de tonnes de
poissons qui prennent par année c'est
trop pour l'environnement mais c'est
aussi trop pour la sécurité alimentaire
surtout quand ils pêchent dans des zones
qui ne leur sont pas réservés grâce au
site globo phishing watch nous avons pu
suivre les déplacements du chalutier
yvan golubev
on constate que le transpondeur
diffusant sa position est souvent et un
en dépit des risques accrus de
collisions avec d'autre navires
pendant les huit jours précédents les
110 le navire est carrément disparu de
la carte mais c'est très suspect de
tendre sans son transport de reyes de
toutes les manières c'est andy qui a une
activité quelconque qui n'est pas
forcément légal qui se déroule
le 19 juillet 2019
le navire prend feu il est remorqué par
un des chalutiers devanture est ce mec
cool avant d'arriver au port le ivan
golub est ce sa cargaison et le corps de
l'aigle nicolescu se retrouve au fond de
l'océan
interviewé par la télévision ukrainienne
dans les jours qui suivent la veuve du
mari disparu crois que le navire a coulé
de façon intentionnelle à nos lettres
sur les chevaux est ce qui nous unit au
niveau de nos les portugais sont les
déportations et en apportant une
nouvelle police d'assurance souscrite
auprès d'un assureur russe est entrée en
vigueur le 19 juillet à minuit soit
quelques heures à peine avant l'
incendie
la société écran de calgary est devenu
bénéficiaire d'une couverture de 15
millions de dollars américains
bien au delà de la valeur réelle du
navire assem 14 frotte je crois qu'il
s'agit d'une fraude
le navire était vieux il semble qu'il y
avait des problèmes avec le bateau ils
ont acheté une police d'assurance et
détruit le navire pour empocher l'argent
via business ou aussi un effet crise
n'ont répondu aux questions que nous
leur avons envoyé par courriel
à notre demande nos collègues la
télévision layton tv3 se sont rendus au
bureau de batterie est un des
propriétaires a annulé une rencontre
prévue avec tv 3d par courriel il
affirme que bolt reds n'a aucun lien
avec les sociétés écrans canadienne il
nie que wall street s'est effectuée de
la pêche illégale de la fraude
d'assurance ou du blanchiment d'argent
evialis nice est aussi en excès chemises
ont reçu plus de 27 millions de dollars
en fonds douteux selon les données de la
fuite
la plupart de ces fonds étaient déposés
dans des comptes bancaires non pas au
canada mais à moscou dans les
succursales de deux banques d'état russe
ça me suggère en fait que les
propriétaires sont effectivement basé en
russie
donc et non pas en lettonie ou now au
canada ou ailleurs ce n'est pas
uniquement les russes qui aiment se
camoufler ce sont généralement les
propriétaires qui savent que leurs
navires ont leur compagnie opère sur la
limite de la légalité voire même dans
l'illégalité
dans un rapport de 2015 le nouveau
brunswick a considéré effectuer des
changements à la loi sur les
corporations commercial reconnaissant la
possibilité d'utiliser une corporation
du nouveau brunswick à des fins
d'escroquerie ou de fraude
internationale
mais rien n'a été fait par craint que le
nouveau brunswick de perdre un avantage
compétitif par rapport aux autres
provinces
je pense et c'est le problème avec le
nouveau brunswick malheureusement on a
longtemps de niveler vers le borgne
longtemps dit bon si les autres le fait
on est aussi bandai d'arracher notre
pièce de joe puisse à faire en sorte que
on a une structure coopérative au
nouveau brunswick qui est très
questionnable
ottawa est en consultation avec les
provinces afin de réviser les règles
pour l'instant le canada demeure une
façade de choix pour des acteurs
internationaux douteux est-ce que c'est
l'agent de juridiction qu'on veut être
est ce qu'on veut devenir le panama ce
qu'on veut devenir les îles vierges
britanniques
la scène internationale c'est la
question qu'on se pose
[Musique]